away from the front line these ukrainian
sailors are in the uk training with the
royal navy and their u.s counterparts
they're learning how to use underwater
mine hunter drones
these vessels search seabed using sonar
technology
they'll be used to identify explosive
threats around ukraine's coastline
this is underwater drone
that will be very useful for us
to clear the
sea area especially the
very critical region in a desk close to
a desert region
to find the mines with this in mind the
sailors here are working long hours
determined to learn the ropes as fast as
possible through interpreters they're
taught how to program and operate the
drones putting practice into action
during regular training exercises at sea
these vessels have been described as a
game changer for the ukrainian navy and
they hope they're going to play a key
part in helping get ships carrying grain
out of the country efforts that so far
have been hampered by sea mines
we've already seen the devastating
impact this conflicts had on the supply
and price of grain globally but these
drones could provide a turning point
they should be able to clear a main
route out of their ports very quickly
that is very important because there is
immense pressure global pressure to
actually start shifting uh what one
could call a grain mountain that's
backing up in ukraine and it's not just
grain it's also vegetable oil and maize
and this needs to start moving
the ukrainian sailors know how important
this is their motivation and urgency is
clear
the ukrainian personnel have been
amazing um their enthusiasm and their
energy levels to be able to both learn
and understand these capabilities is is
truly remarkable it's also inspiring um
the fact that they know what this
capability will give them when they go
back home is what's driving them and so
to work with them and have the
opportunity to work with them uh is a
real privilege
within weeks over a dozen ukrainian
sailors will be fully trained and in
total the uk and us will gift them with
six drones
these new skills and gifts will be
invaluable in the fight against russia
aisha zahid sky news